we had ivan not
thriving ben
back again
and tasha is engaged
to zach yes everybody this is your the
bachelorette season finale part two
it is really over live recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rose
babes it's me lauren zema
and it is the finale the big
finish the big final it's really done
and we are here to talk about everything
that we just witnessed including a
spoiler alert
i mean it's too late but spoiler alert
tasia is engaged
and on that note we have look at this a
beautiful ring
celebrating the engagement oh my gosh oh
my gosh you just saw it but let's look
at it again
a cake a cake with tasha's face on it
because you guys know
i can love cake and you know what what
better time to put a
face on a cake than the bachelorette
finale and of course you know i love
rose look at this
we have got a pin in it both the season
and my hair and it says rose yes
i am all about the fit right now
everyone i mean look i got to say i kind
of brought it this is a full
black velvet pant suit for the finale
everybody
we are here we are doing it let's get to
it
first i've got to pour my rose hey of
course and we do have a classic rose
because i like to end the finale strong
on a beautiful
light rose that we know and love
everybody
cheers to tasha what did you think of
this final final episode
let me know in the comments below did
you predict the outcome did you think
that tasha would get engaged
to zach did you think that she'd send
ivan home did you think that she'd sent
ben home
again how poor
ben right let me know in the comments
below because
i am taking your comments and questions
live i'm getting them
right here on this ipad and i want to
hear from you guys
what you thought what you were shocked
by how you feel are we crying oh we've
done the seasons crying
all right anyway seriously let's get to
it
again as a reminder we are live so i got
to do my own graphics which i kind of
love doing
look at that our graphics department's
gonna hate me for that their job is much
more difficult than i just made that
look
all right so first of all everybody we
pick up
where we left off after monday night's
episode
ben had returned tasha didn't know what
she was going to do with it
well we found out ben and tasha are
talking and
i really felt like ben could see
intacia's eyes that something was there
you know
and and he was kind of smiling and kind
of looking at her in that ben
captain america way and uh you know what
fantasia says she has to think and ben
thinks he's gonna seal the deal with his
big move
a kiss so don't drink for the whole time
ben went in for the kiss
[Music]
ben showing up tonight affects
everything
and i just don't want to make a bad
decision
and i just kissed him why would i kiss
him
why did i do that
why did she do that babes why did she
do that what did you think i think she
did that because she loves to kiss ben
you know what i'm saying um ben does
that thing i've talked about it all
season he grabs the neck he pulls you in
i think ben's a good kisser and actually
i know he is because i asked tasha about
it when i
uh did an interview with her and she
said he was the best
kisser so
you know take what you do what you owe
with that
what did you guys think of that moment
did you
feel that tasha should have brought ben
back into the fold after just
sending him home i have to say i kind of
felt like we were back in
bennett's territory again not to bring
up what might be a sore subject for some
of you but
i don't know it's been a lot of like
back and forthing with the guys this
season at this point all right your
comments and questions
are coming in and
katie ann says she cried so hard during
the proposal we are going to talk about
it liz says that she doesn't feel tasha
is ready to marry
any of these guys she just really likes
zach but he's not sure it will work out
betsy says it was a beautiful proposal
but i was hoping she would pick ben well
she didn't then okay so and then
and then and then it's the rose ceremony
and
from one guy being brought back to
another being sent home i could not
believe this you guys
so ivan and zach are standing there and
then walks ben look at ivan's eyes he's
like what the f
zack had kind of a chill reaction i sort
of like that zach is unflinched by
anything he was like whatever man
i haven't stressed out ivan's wearing a
turtleneck let's pour one out for
brendan
why did these men think they needed to
wear turtlenecks in palm springs all
season
i thought it was just brendan apparently
not maybe he left it for ivan is good
luck
but that turtleneck would not prove to
be useful because
tasha comes out and she pulls ivan aside
and she tells ivan that
this came out of nowhere for me babes
what did you think she tells ivan
that their religion issue is too big of
a roadblock for them to overcome now i
know she'd mentioned after their fantasy
suite that they talked about religion
but
this just came again out of left field
for me uh to use a sports reference
i had not heard them talk about religion
i didn't know
that it was a point of contention for
them just last night we were here in
taisha say that ivan is literally
perfect but
this kind of spoke to what i think uh i
said last night that
i feel like taysha knows ivan's a great
guy he checks all the boxes but
something was missing and i think it was
both a spark
and just maybe like that deep connection
and maybe the religious issue was either
a really real problem or
you know she just needed to put a label
on what wasn't working
so were you shocked because then
what happens is tasha sends ivan home
and the car is pulling away and i gotta
say
it wasn't very emotional
i mean i thought we were gonna get some
tears let's not forget that tasha cried
over
blake like i couldn't believe this
ivan's going he's not crying tasia's not
crying listen to what i haven't had to
say
i think this is a lot harder than tysha
imagined
and i don't know if she'll feel
comfortable really with anybody by the
end of this
because i think me and her made the most
sense
it's gonna be tough on her but i don't
she's not gonna pick anybody i don't
think
you know hindsight's 20 20. but
she did pick someone ivan she did it was
interesting though because as you guys
were just commenting some of you saying
you didn't think taisha was ready i
guess ivan didn't think that tasha was
ready either
oh okay more comments coming in kelly
says poor ivan need to know why kathy
says ivan was husband material she blew
it i think tasha knew he was husband
material
she just didn't seem to want that
material
she was interested in a different fabric
i suppose
it comes down to what it often does you
know in
on this show and in life i think just
that extra spark
um so sarah says oh zach is mature
enough to have a long engagement that's
why she picked him interesting you know
let's just
take a little drink for ivan because man
he was great
if we didn't already have our bachelor
material in matt because of the way the
production schedule worked out
do you guys think ivan would have made a
good bachelor
i do let me know in the comments below
all right so
this means that ben is
back again a ben
a ben is back he and zach
are going to meet tasha's family and oh
my gosh i was so excited for this
because i love tasha's dad back on
colton's season
when he uh said something about how you
shouldn't microwave love he does not
mess around this man
so tasha's brothers are here her mom and
her dad
and you know what oh emily says i am
loving tasha's dad i am too
so don't drink for all the amazing
reactions that tasha's dad had
to her telling him what had been going
on
let's see how she's been
[Applause]
so what is uh tasia what are you doing
where are we at what are we doing ben
actually went home but ben came back
he showed back up on my doorstep what
oh that man an eyebrow raise is worth a
thousand words
from mr adams i love him
do you guys love tasha's dad i really
adore when the parents win the family
are characters on the show you know well
let's raise our glasses to barb remember
her
um but how could we forget why did i
even say that um but he was amazing so
he's there and he doesn't mess around he
doesn't mince words
he raises his eyebrows and he
uh seems like he's gonna be pretty
skeptical about this whole thing
ben comes and meets attacha's family and
i thought things went
fine solidly i mean you know what's not
to like about ben when you meet him
especially just for this little amount
of time i don't think there was any
issue that they noticed in this
conversation uh
i did have an issue with again one of
our final
events towards the end here i am so
[ __ ] sick of the scooters you guys
don't drink for all the scooters they
rode at the end here
[Music]
i'm so happy that i came back i'm so
happy that i got to meet her family i'm
so grateful
that she like took me back her
family likes me i can see myself fitting
in with her family
all right so tasha and i are out of here
for the night it was great to meet you
all
i love you love you look where you're
going girl
they scooted away like
we had to end the season here because we
have run out of things to do
at the la quinta okay i have to say
matt james's season of the bachelor
which is coming up in hold on hold on
hold on
shameless plug just a few weeks
they also filmed it at one resort uh
this time in pennsylvania but i think
they had more to do so i'm excited for
that they had a bigger property there
different weather it wasn't so hot so
we're gonna get some more fun activities
for matt james this season
can't watch any more scooters uh but
let's metaphorically
scoot on uh to you guys's comments
jordan says please make ben the next
bachelor
it's interesting you guys we don't
usually have this
lack of speculation about who the next
lead's gonna be right
because the pandemic changed filming
they had to name matt james earlier as
the bachelor
so that they could keep the shows going
and usually we'd be wondering who will
the next bachelor be we'd be
you know speculating an announcement
will be coming soon
i gotta say unless one of these guys
goes on paradise and like
stays strong in the fans minds i don't
predict that we're gonna get
a bachelor from post matt james a season
from this crew
that's my guess because we still have a
whole nother season of the bachelorette
before we get the next season of the
bachelor so we're gonna have another
crop of guys
i'm just saying i'm just saying um so
kenneth says they scooted off into the
sunset they didn't though you know
because she's not with ben
so let's talk about zach and tasha zach
goes to meet tasha's family and i did
love how serious zach took this you know
he sat down with her dad and he said
look
you've set this high standard of how to
treat your daughter and that doesn't
scare me i'm serious here i want to
do what's right and be the best man for
tasha
he is so serious about this that they
are going to eat some new york pizza
if there's one thing we know about zach
is he's from new york and if there's one
thing i know about this pizza it's that
to be honest it didn't look that great
how long had it been sitting
in the palm desert sun i have questions
i have questions i wanted to dab it
right off of the napkin but
you know what again we're running out of
things to do
so everything's going fine until
tasha's dad comes and talks to her in
private and i
need you guys thoughts on this because i
didn't fully know how to process it
he comes and here's a little snippet
of some of the stuff he said to her take
a listen
seeing these guys you know we don't want
things to go backwards for you
it might not be what you want to hear
but
i don't want you to be making the
biggest mistake of your life
did that mean that tasha's dad
i make that mistake on purpose a lot did
that mean that tasha's dad
didn't think tasha should be with either
zach or ben
let me know in the comments below that
was the takeaway i had from the
conversation it seemed to me
that tasha's dad again he was with her
through her divorce
and tasha said he really saw her true
pain talked about how he sat in the car
with her once while she screamed and
cried and you just sat next to her
my heart so it seemed to me like tasha's
dad
didn't think either of these guys were
really the one for tasha
but was i reading that wrong let me know
in the comments below um
robin robertson says thank god she
didn't pick ben why robin why
do you guys love ben still i mean i i
still think ben's great
something something wasn't there so
tasha is wondering should she get
engaged
are these guys right for her and she
goes and talks to zach
and she seems to tell zach that she's
worried that
she's missing something that she's not
seeing something that could go wrong
she's wondering what will happen once
we're out of here
and again i was a little confused here
she started talking about would he still
like her if she wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom i i think maybe this
was justia being kind of gun shy from
having been divorced and having been on
the shows before she was on colton's
season the bachelor she was on bachelor
in paradise
i think she was just worried she might
be missing something
and then
zach kind of reassures her he says look
i'm in he talks about how
he is celebrating the anniversary of his
sobriety
and how he's found everything in her
and this seemed to be the clarity i had
to do it one more time
vita was looking for because she then
says she's realized
her heart is not
within
i was a little surprised there you guys
i was tasha goes and talks to ben
i did not think she was going to send
him home before the proposal moment
it felt like he'd been there and back
and gone again in a hot second that's
why it reminded me of bennett it's like
hey you've come back
for you know half a day to meet my
family to get completely emotionally
involved to tell me that you love me but
bye it's not working for me
so she tells him she's done
and uh let's listen to what ben had to
say
i put all of myself into this
so um
i thought i was gonna be her husband
i'm still he
thought he was gonna be her husband
[Music]
don't drink for all ben's pain what did
you guys think
i i gotta say i saw where ben was coming
from he's thinking she's brought me back
here
so it must be because i'm the one right
no ben's there and back again um
you know what don't drink for the whole
time ben was just going home in the car
and it was completely heartbreaking
all the things that i was looking for
all the things that i saw in her
all of the beauty that she has
our life would have been so good
[Music]
she was perfect for me
beth he said their life would have been
so good she was perfect for him
was she did you think taste should be
with ben let me know in the comments
below
so she's not uh and uh
you know teresa says stacia had the best
wardrobe bunny bachelorette i agree
eddie says we need your harry potter
voldemort impression at least one more
time i will deliver thank you eddie stay
tuned
how could we not um so tisha's getting
ready
and she's getting ready to get proposed
to right and she
is still worried about things changing
with zack i have to say i was a little
worried as she was getting ready for the
proposal
about how tense tasha seemed i was
thinking i don't want her to feel this
way
on the day of her proposal right um then
we see zach picking out the ring and
talking about finding the woman of his
dreams and my worry was zach and you
know i
if i do an interview with them i i do
want to ask them is like zack
how did you kind of know that you
yourself wanted to make this big change
he just before going on the show it said
he didn't even really want to get
married
i want to know why he went on the show
and how he knew that the change for him
was right
versus just being caught up in the
feelings for tasha i have these
questions
by the way uh gorgeous look on tasha i
mean let's just
get to the proposal moment and talk
about how incredibly stunning she looked
um zach is walking up
tasha is looking gorgeous zach says
among many
honestly beautiful romantic things he
says quote
there are moments in life you wait your
entire existence for
and this is one of those moments
you guys i thought everything that zach
had to say was pretty amazing i i got
pretty swept up in it so let's let's
take a listen
nothing has ever felt so right
my entire life you've
helped me experience a love that i
didn't know existed
zach says that he loves tasha because
she's a strong
independent woman he says he loves her
because she makes everyone around her
better
and i thought to myself this is a mature
man talking because these are reasons
that you should love a person right and
they are holding each other they are
crying and they are caressing i am
getting totally caught up in and how did
you guys feel during this proposal
moment
you know what let's just get totally
swept up in it let's hold each other's
hands and by each other's hands i mean
our glasses of wine
don't drink for everything that tasha
had to say to zach
because at the end here i thought she
might have been turning him down
everybody don't drink for tasha i know
that i
told you that i love you
sorry
it's more than that
it's this wild wild love that
i have tried to come up with
so many reasons to not believe and you
have truly
just made me believe that there doesn't
need to be flaws and that i deserve a
love with a man that won't run away
oh tasia that was the answer i was
looking for you guys i had been
wondering
as we'd heard tasha say that ivan was
literally everything that brendan was
the one she saw herself with that ben
was awesome
how did she pick zach and i think that
is the difference she said and i quote
it's this wild wild love she said that
it is
more than just saying i love you and
they were in tears together and it was
pretty beautiful and zach gets down on
one knee
and he tells her he is going to choose
her all the time they are both crying
and here is what tasia says in response
to
the proposal
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh come on
the music was swelling i was swept up in
it i thought it was a little surprising
that zach said yes
but i didn't hate it
he's like this like new yorker guy and
then at the end he gets engaged he goes
yes
great love it sack um so
zach and tasha are engaged
again tell me if you guys were surprised
they're toasting here i love it
a little surprising that tasha is who's
probably mentioned donuts
almost once an episode uh she just finds
out that zach likes donuts and she's
like okay great i'm like how did we not
ask about that
um they talked about having kids she
says that he's the gas and she's the
brakes
that surprised me a little bit too
because i i thought they were really on
the same page but a lot of this stuff i
don't know i have
questions and i will say we should be
interviewing them
so a little shameless plug we'll have
that interview for you tomorrow at
etonline.com
um we are going to take a few more of
your comments
uh they everybody loved the taxi at the
end yes that
taxi pulled up no noelle and sue loved
it
um for tasha and zach madison says i've
never cried during a proposal before but
i cried during this one
alice says best proposal ever um
danielle says so perfect maria says it
takes a says a lot about zach that he
took all of tasha's concerns
in stride it was really romantic you
guys truly i
adore tasha so much i've called her the
angel mermaid goddess human
she has just been so mature and
beautiful during all this that i really
wanted to be happy now
i will say i didn't know probably until
tonight
who she was gonna pick she seemed so
in focus with all the guys and they all
seem so into her
but zach he's never done anything to
scare her you know as much as tasha said
she she's tried to find the flaws there
haven't been any with zach he's been
totally focused on her the whole time
so i raised my glass to zach and tasha
and their
engagement and i can't wait to see what
happens next we're going to talk to them
tomorrow
uh brooke wants a life update so does
lilly we're going to get it tomorrow you
guys
now oh hold on hold on the shameless
plug yes we're gonna talk to them and
another shameless plug
from mature to mess we are gonna only
have
one week off of roses and rose for a
little uh holiday new year moment and
then
it is back to your screens with matt
james's season of the bachelor and oh i
say
mess because it looks like it is going
to be a beautiful bless
this mess drama filled season we're
getting shirtless matt james
we're getting make out sessions we are
getting
horseback riding all the bachelor things
that we know and love and
i think we're getting some ladies who
are gonna cause some drama
yes yes yes uh there was if you guys
watch the pro
promo for this season there's apparently
accusations that a woman is someone who
has sugar daddies
i have a lot of questions so everybody
matt james the season of the bachelor
premieres
january 4th and we will be here to talk
about it on roses and rose
i also want to give a shout out to our
team who is so wonderful thank you to
our editor jc our producers chris san
and so many other people who helped with
our live show tonight
and you guys you know that i love tik
tok and you know that i love cake
so we gotta do a little tick tock thing
and try eating a piece of this cake
here we go have you seen this you do the
cake with a glass
and oh wow that's efficient everybody
i love it so much i love you all if you
want to talk to me and connect more
we are able you can find me on cameo
twitter and tick tock and all that i
love you guys so much thank you for
watching roses and rose see you next
season
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you